hello my name is Noel Y and I live at
the Vulcan in East Oakland California
and for my Aja 2012 video competition I
will be doing a reverse boy fishtail and
it looks a little bit like
this a fishtail is a trick that can be
TR transferred between a wide variety of
props it can be incorporated into your
Club
[Music]
swinging your contact staff or staff
spinning or even random objects in case
you want to do it for a renegade show
the fishtail has a learning curve very
similar to traditional juggling props it
takes dedication time and a little
practice to get solid
the traditional fish tail with the rigid
prop like a staff or Club one end of the
staff does not leave the one side of the
body the PO fish tail is a little bit
different the handle of the POI switches
from parallel ples each side this is the
difference that makes the POI fishtail
different from the normal rigid prop
fishtail and so interesting and
fun it is best to practice poish tails
with the type of poi called a contact
POI the POI head is a ball and the
handle is weighted to provide
counterweight for your fish tail you can
begin with any poy but I suggest the
contact poy as the illusion of the fish
tail is maintained here I'm using an 80
mm stage ball and a set of flow cord
from flow
TOS the next most important thing you
want to practice is to think about which
CR
you'd like to learn for your contact boy
fish tail so here we
[Music]
go I like the three-finger cradle here
because it's prettier than the four
finger cradle and it's not as hard as a
two finger cradle but anyone you choose
will
work in the first of our four drills you
will not be using any poy at all taking
a stage ball and putting it into your
favorite
cradle move the ball around from side to
side changing between parallel planes
after you're comfortable give it a
little hop The Hop should happen at the
very center line of your body this this
will get you used to the string and
handle switching from side to
[Music]
side another drill teaches us how to
move from a hold into a
balance to begin grab the head of the
poy and swing in reverse on one side of
your body give the PO a little toss and
balance it on the back of your hand
absorbing the impact toss it back up and
catch it in the hand again when you're
comfortable with this catch go ahead and
try balancing your hand and Swinging the
handle to the other side of your
body try to make sure that you're giving
it a little bit of a pop As you move it
to the other side to get that handle
over one beat to the Wayside and then
back home and stop don't try to keep
going quite yet just try to get started
with two beats and eventually you move
up to more and more
[Music]
in the third drill you start by swinging
your PO back and forth on your side and
as the PO handle is on the way up swing
the handle to the other side and stop
and end in the swing I find this drill
focuses the attention on The Swinging
aspect of the fish tail if you find it
difficult to stop on the other side go
back and practice your basic balance
[Music]
the fourth po fishtail drill starts by
adding a softer swing to the technique
start by holding the handle in one hand
and the ball in the other and drop the
handle and try to get a few rotations
out of the PO and then recatch in the
original position once again build up
with two beads then gradually add more
until it's
comfy practicing all four of these po
fishtail drills will improve your
fishtails drastically some drills work
for some people some work for others so
pick the ones you like best and work on
those or maybe come up with your
own remember small steps try to get one
beat of the fish tail and then two and
then three and then build up build up
confidence while practicing
[Music]
darling darling darling
time down
[Music]
thanks for watching my Ig tutorial video
on reverse po fish tailes subscribe uh
become a member of the A and uh see you
next time bye
[Music]